right here ready to plant and we've got
a beautiful machine here that we're
hopefully going to figure out how to use
now uh first thing I guess is the
question why are we going to use machine
transplanting we could also do manual
planting so why are we doing this Lee
well trying to act in as a contemporary
way as possible and I think uh labor
supplies in Asia are declining uh
everywhere as as the whole continent
develops and systems to use less
Labor uh evolving as we speak and one
way of using less labor is still to
transplant because there's benefits in
transplanting but to do it mechanically
now this this sort of machine was
invented in in Japan how long ago 40
years ago probably 20 30 years ago at
least yeah it's been these kind of
things have been in use in Japan Korea
maybe China but what we're seeing in
recent years is that it's now moving on
to into other countries in India
southeast Asia and it's mainly because
of Labor shortage and it's actually a
business opportunity not just for the
company selling the machines but also
for small farmers who then become uh
small entrepreneurs to providing this as
a service as a planting service to other
farmers and even for seedling Growers
you because you need to have uh
seedlings grown in a in a precise manner
you can see this here if you can zoom in
I don't know if you guys can do this
yeah so you need these nice uh ceiling
mats here though you can see how uniform
the ceilings are and it's of course it
requires a special way of growing them
so that you can pull them off in this
muds and cut them into nice stps which
you can then feed into this machine yeah
and this is actually a new business yeah
even for women we see this in some
places in in Southern India I've seen it
so women becoming seedling Growers
selling the seedlings then to a machine
operator or service provider so what
we're basically trying to do this year
here is a labor saving cost efficient
precise crop establishment technology
that is as close as it gets and maybe
even better than manual transplanting
right but but wait a minute last year we
were talking about exactly the same
things and off we went up to just over
our knees in mud broadcasting so what's
changed why why why this sudden change
of heart well because I think uh we we
will get u a more precise crop
establishment with this as a safer
technology to start was under our
conditions here with that kind of heavy
and soft so and we may still try
something else the next Dr is more dry
direct
[Applause]
to see if you're a hand seating would
want G some f right that's right that's
right should have been using a carabell
drawn mechanical transplanter just give
us some more give us some more grain to
[Applause]
eat
yeah we're nearly finished and um by and
large I would say it works but it is
actually quite hard work uh to walk even
behind this machine because anytime you
hit a a deep uh muddy spot you have to
make sure that the wheels don't spin off
and we've had a number of uh patches
there with standing water where
basically it's so mdy that the ceedings
because they're so small disappear you
so but uh here is a place where uh looks
quite okay so you can
see pretty good spacing and ceilings uh
that hopefully uh will recover and go
quickly uh but uh it has taken us a
while and the Machine is uh the engine
died a couple of times on the way the
planting mechanism got stuck once in a
while so
it requires some skill I would say of
course um a trained operator a
professional would have done this much
faster and probably better than we did
but uh well we got it planted now let's
see how it goes
so